and now we will learn about uh the
sessions uh how the second part of the
sessions will be day two and day three
and before that let me just quickly tell
you that what it will be about so
uh again thank you dr preet now uh let's
learn about the topic and let's learn
about what would be the base of this so
that in this introductory workshop our
focus will be
uh to give you an in-depth overview of
important omics technologies that is
changing the way
healthcare is and this entire system is
rapidly evolving so our focus will be to
making you learn about these complex
technologies with
several different layers so that it
becomes easy for you to learn and you
have sample amount of resources with you
to take you uh which you can take on for
the next few next one month to learn
about all of this so we will learn about
obviously the next generation sequencing
technologies and the data the different
omics layer data and then we will also
learn about how this in it all
integrates into drug discovery and how
this is actually helping in the process
of drug discovery so we will start with
genomics like giving you an overview of
genomics that genomics is an essential
subfield of bioinformatics and it's a
very important field now it's a and
which is a major force in expanding our
knowledge about genetic association with
hume with diseases and other traits
so uh it's an interdisciplinary field so
in such interdisciplinary field we have
an opportunity also to learn about other
things so the other things would be to
learn about r and python how r in python
is used in genomics what are the
different way i mean technologies or
different algorithms that we use in
genomics to gain insights about
different things such as you know
multiple sequence alignment of genomes
then we are talking about you know dna
methylation factors then we are talking
about massive databases such as gene
back gene bank embl and sra that allows
us to do all of this research so this
will be focused on that and this is what
genomics is going to be all about in
this
workshop
and then
another technology that you are going to
learn about so there are three key
technologies that we are going to cover
uh in this workshop along with hemo
information chemi informatics is
genomics transcriptomics and
metagenomics so transcriptomics is the
process by which the information in a
stand of dna is copied into a new
molecule of rna so this transcript this
transcription is like a dynamic process
right so the transcriptome is a snapshot
of genes transcribed in a cell at a
particular point of time and this is
very important to learn that this is
complete snapshot of
the entire genes at a particular point
of time so this actually enables us to
gain a lot of information when we
compare different uh
stages different uh conditions
so that's why we learn so much about
transcriptomics and that's why it has
been used in uh so much in clinics and
in research
so um the sum total uh that is what the
transcriptome is all about and then we
are going to learn about uh different
analytical steps so how do you analyze
once you have the transcriptomic data
it's deposited in public repositories
and you can answer some good questions
some about good biological research
questions
like biomarkers and
finding critical genes that are
expressed at a certain point of time
that gives you an idea about their
function so all of that is can be done
through transcriptomics and uh what we
are going to learn is that how do you do
the processing so from a raw data so you
will learn about the raw data in on 26
december and on 27th december we will be
learning about how do you process this
raw data into something meaningful so
processing exploring and we learn about
gene and isoforms downstream analysis
statistical analysis and then
interpretation of that kind of data so
that that would be one of the key
objectives of this workshop to get you
comfortable with the visual tbi info
platform to get you comfortable with the
research that can be done using such
tools and algorithms
sorry
and the next thing would be
after transcriptomics is also to learn
about metagenomics not after but we are
going to learn about these
simultaneously in a way that it all
makes sense so in metagenomics we would
be learning about microorganisms and
then
the samples that are collected from the
natural environment and we will be
learning about the community structure
because in a natural environment you'll
find all kind of species richness and
then you will be investigating their
functional roles and how these microbial
communities are playing a key role
in human health human disease and many
sort of interactions that we are
learning from this sort of data
so uh again we will be going through
some of the project examples and i will
take you in a sec in a few few more
slides the entire schedule of the
program so
here we will be going through the gut
microbiome project we will learn about
that we will learn about brain
access project and then we will learn
about how this is being useful for those
who do not have any background of micro
technology and people who do have a
background can explode more further this
like meta genomic sequencing uh analysis
you know phylosec and all the
biome
analysis that one can do with the tools
that we will be showcasing you and with
the
resources tutorials that you can take
help from to do this on your own
so uh learning about the technologies
omix technologies genetic data and now
you're looking for solution strategies
now you're looking for molecules you're
looking into structure you're into
three-dimensional world so uh from three
dimension to two dimension from two
dimension that is the sequence uh uh two
you know
sorry
single dimension to
multi-dimensional data and from
multi-dimensional data we move to a
three-dimensional data and again from
three-dimensional data we will move to
again
matrices so again uh two-dimensional
data to do data science and ai so this
is really a fascinating journey from
different type of data types that we
were going to
learn about in this
short workshop it is just to give you
that what all can be done within this
space so one of the things that is going
to be covered is protein folding
structure prediction because when you
think about
you know these
important biological processes you think
about also the diseases you think about
also what is available and what is not
available for a computational biologist
and for a person who does not uh you
know have
all the resources to do the experiments
uh we kind of rely on predictions and we
do predictions all the time we humans do
it all the time so we also uh have built
systems to do better prediction one of
that system is google's deep minds alpha
phone so we will be learning about how
to run alpha fold and what are the
applications of alpha fold with
different variations variants that
you're learning about how that
influences the structure and the
function
now uh now we are back to the schedule
uh for uh actually the day one and day
two after the orientation session on
26th this is 27th and 28th and we have
uh sessions starting from 11
10 45 a.m
to uh 6 p.m till 6 p.m in the evening
and this all of this will be recorded
and will be shared for those who are
missing out on any of the sessions but
it would be a great experience starting
from the beginning till the end we will
start with the orientation of the
program to the program we will see if
you have the learn profiles up and you
will see if you have the
resources
emailed to you and all of that that you
prepared for the session to start and do
some hands-on experience and learn from
the experts so we will start from uh
introduction to ngs technologies
different type of technologies that i
just described to you by taking some
examples and learning some
of some of the pipelines that what we
can
experience and what you can extract and
how do you run the pipeline what are the
different components there so you gonna
you're going to learn about
genomics uh metagenomics and then
transcriptomics with example pipelines
then there is a lunch break obviously we
all get tired and after that we have
after the lunch break we will have the
session on how do you go next after you
run the pipeline how do you do with that
what are the different outputs what are
the different analysis method and how do
you interpret that that would be for one
hour and after that we will have uh so
these sessions will be
divided into again two sessions so once
for uh the first session we will be
learning about the mutation uh we will
be learning about genomic visualization
then we will be learning about the
mutation and variant analysis that you
can do with genomics so here you're
learning about genomics you're learning
about application of genomics before
that you got an overview of all the
omics technology and you would learn
about different
pipelines that you can use to analyze
such data after that uh when we are done
with
around 2 30 p.m so after that we start
with us specialization tracks which is
from 2 30 p.m to 3 30 p.m and this is
indian standard time so you can change
it according to your time zone
now uh we have uh in that session uh we
have application of ngs so we will be
learning about the tcga project and then
then we would be learning about uh some
of the
projects related to covet 19 sequencing
so that is not mentioned here and we
have included that now so waste water
management so we will learn about three
case studies in brief here and then we
will actually work on those case studies
later in the last session so here you
will get an overview of what the case
studies are all about and what are we
going to do and then we will have a tea
break
so after the d break we will start with
k informatics application and case study
we will go over some of the softwares
that are being used in kemi informatics
and give you an idea of how and what are
what are the things that are
that you can start with using some of
the tools that are available online then
we will start with the last session
which is a breakout session where you
can choose uh that which session you
want to um you're more interested in so
is it like machine learning and drug
efficacy and or and learning about
learning our projects that are available
applying transcriptomics analysis or
genomics analysis or uh you know
structural analysis so we will have
three rooms uh any of you which you can
join and we'll be having obviously the
recording so you can
learn about the different sessions later
as well if you're registered participant
in the second day we will go through the
statistical analysis because all of
these technologies are producing you a
table so that table is again like a
matrix it has rows it has columns and it
is a very big table so how do you un
interpret that table we will apply uh
methodologies algorithms such as
degs
uh some understand about the beta
diversity and you learn about from the
structural perspective as well so after
that session when we are
well versed with what all that you can
expect from this kind of data what is
the way to
learn how to extract meaningful data
because one of the challenges with big
data analysis and being a data scientist
is that you have to
analyze big data and then you have to
find you know
critical information from a huge amount
of information so that's really a
challenge because data annotation is
again
very trivial thing
so
we will learn about that in the next
session that how that how you can
explore and explore data how which you
don't have any no idea about that is
unsupervised machine learning and then
supervised machine learning and we have
an expert with us on deep learning dr
raghavendra as you have heard from him
so he will be taking us from that
different uh different types of
algorithms that are used for such
analysis and then from a biological
standpoint what all of this analysis is
making sense you need to learn about
that right you need to learn that why we
are doing this why we are using machine
learning and from what we are getting
from machine learning and why it is
helpful for biology so that is the
connection to the biology downstream
analysis pathway analysis how it is
affecting the pathways if there are
mutations how it is affecting the how it
is becoming cancerous and how it is
applicable for
meta genomics and then we have an
industrial panel discussion and we have
presentations and discussions where we
will be telling you about the
opportunities that are upcoming so
internship opportunities or job
opportunities or
the things that you need to
be prepared for to get a job in the
industry we will be hearing from some of
the industry panels coming from
premier's life sciences and pine barra
tech and then we have the certification
and
um
q a and networking where you can
you know network with the
community and discuss and do all of the
interaction that can help you uh maybe
get different opportunities that are
there so um that's about the workshop
and that's about the entire curriculum
about the workshop and
if you have any questions about the
curriculum and all of that i'm happy to
answer to those questions and now
i will invite mr malik if she is around
to take you through the registration and
this workshop
uh registration
fees and all of that and also the
resources that you will have thank you
thank you everyone